hey guys Pete here this will be my mr.
robot season 4 episode 8 recap and
review episode 8 was titled 408 request
timeout was written by robbie pickering
and directed by series creator Sam s
mail this episode had a tough job of
falling one of the most emotional
installments of the series and while
it's unlikely going in that it can top
that I think it did what it had to do
it's still Christmas Day and going into
this episode I was wondering how they're
going to manage giving Elliott some time
to process what he just learned about
his childhood trauma in light of the
upcoming Deus group meeting I think they
found a way that works let Janice do the
heavy lifting
let DOM get out from under the weight of
the dark army so that she can shine a
bit for the first time this season and
let Elliott go inside himself to start
to work out how to face this new truth
that he's kept repressed the nearly
catatonic state we find Elliott in at
the beginning of the episode makes
perfect sense he's just learned that he
was sexually abused by his father in the
middle of orchestrating a hack against
the most powerful people in the world
which he needs to pull off because his
survival depends on it he has every
reason to believe that White Rose will
have him killed once her project ships
no reason to believe that she won't and
that doesn't afford too many other
chances but to continue out in New
Jersey we see that Dom's family is all
gathered together for the holiday this
makes them a perfect target and their
get together it gets interrupted by a
gang of intruders wearing ski masks and
carrying zip ties from there we make our
first check-in with Janice Tom and
Darlene Janice does all the things that
Janice does best as she makes
conversation about how cement was
discovered through one perfect moment of
violent convergence before outing Dom
for pleasuring yourself to Darlene's
interrogation video when she finds out
that the dark army can't recover
anything from the phone she takes this
as her cue and stabs Dom in the lung to
put the pressure on this sets up a slow
inevitable death that only Janice can
undo she says that she'll call for help
and that she won't kill Dom's family but
not until Darlene gives up Ellie its
location the tension throughout this
side of the story is fantastic all the
way through and when Darlene is
eventually forced to give in she can't
find
Eliott back in the city Christa has her
own stuff to process after plunging a
knife into bears back but she's able to
get Elliot out of the apartment and into
a cab she tells the cab driver to take
them to the nearest police station as
the video with Tyrell in it wishes
everyone a Merry Christmas on behalf of
ecore when they get to the police
station in Elliott can't go in and he's
not sure how to go on he asked Christa
what do people do people like me when
they find out about something like this
what can they do she responds they just
try to keep going and that's what
Elliott has to do while they're talking
he sees a younger version of himself
standing at the train station across the
street he follows him to the Queens
Museum where we know he used to run away
to with Angela when they were kids
in the beginning of the episode we see
him sneak inside into the storage area
and hide something in the wall I imagine
that this is a real memory something
that happened but when he talks to his
younger self I can't say for sure if
that is happening in the real world or
if that's happening inside his head it
mostly plays like it's actually
happening but the whole going inside the
museum in the evening is a little bit
suspect and it's the way that they film
it they don't actually show them enter
the door well it may have happened or it
may not have it's not really important
the important thing is is what happens
when he's inside there what he discovers
in the wall and what he discovers about
himself so I don't think this is the
kind of mystery that needs to be solved
like did he really go in or not that we
need to really look at the clues because
in the end it's what happens inside of
him that helps him move forward his
younger self is there to help him
process at one point he screams an
apology because he feels bad that he
didn't fight back he didn't protect this
version of himself from his dad who was
hurting him earlier there's a really
touching moment when he's talking to
Krista and he said he made me feel
special and she points out that it's not
his fault he was a kid he wasn't in
control but he's still grappling with
this it's hard to imagine in retrospect
that there wasn't something that he
could do the key here is literally a key
the reason that his younger self brought
him back to this museum was to show him
what they hid and we find out it was the
key to his bedroom door and it wasn't
his key it was his father's
he takes the key thinking that he can
stop him from entering his room whenever
he wants so in the only way a kid can he
is actually fighting back the discovery
of this lets him forgive himself and
he's able to move on at least in the
moment and go back to allsafe the key of
course is something we've seen before
this popped up way back in season 1
episode 4 when Elliott has his dream in
that the key that we see here keeps
popping back up and we hear references
to his monster which we also hear again
in this episode we can make a connection
that his father was his monster or the
abuse was his monster or that repressing
this is the monster that he kept hidden
I don't know if we can take that as a
full explanation of what that dreams
supposed to represent but it does seem
to at least fill in some of the
information that we've been thinking
about there for so long the realization
seems to open the door for mr. robot to
return there was a lot of discussion
about whether he would or were not
returned I thought that he probably
would and it's good to see that they
didn't drag that out as far as I'm
concerned the idea being what I said in
my last recap mr. robot is not his
father
he's an invention to be the father that
he didn't have and he says that here he
tells Elliott I'm not your father
which Elliott replies I know that's why
I created you you're the father I needed
not the father I had and this is
Christian Slater's chance to shine here
we got great performances by everyone in
the last episode but he wasn't front and
center in the way that the other
characters were and here we see that
this is a two-way street he wishes he
could undo what happened he wishes that
he hadn't kept this hidden because he
sees it was the wrong thing to do but
Elliott does have someone that he can
work with and trust in mr. robot at this
point and it feels like on some levels
it's the only way he could go on and
we'll get to that in a second
back at Angela's apartment Janus kicks
things into high gear because she's not
getting what she wants she decides that
this is the time to start killing Dom's
family one by one
and things feel pretty dire because we
know that Darlene can't actually find
Elliot she gets on the phone though and
no one's picking up we see the shot of
the phone with blood on it that we saw
in the trailers over and over again and
we realized that Dom had something up
her sleeve so it turns out that this guy
Deegan who we've seen in earlier
episodes and we thought that probably it
was maybe an exit plan for Dom she must
have helped him some way to get him out
of his charges where he is indebted to
her to protect her family from the dark
army when the time came
turns out he's really good at it and
what's more the conversation between him
and Janice is top-notch Janice has this
way of being really kind of creepy and
normal and just all business and this
guy is definitely the right person
because he seems like he might even be a
little bit more into his job than she is
so they have a pretty awesome back and
forth we learned that he's the one that
has her family that they're safe at
least for the moment and Deegan doesn't
care about Janice of the dark army he's
not worried because he's taking care of
things as this is all going down Dom
uses the distraction to her advantage
she pulls the knife out of her chest the
one that's keeping her alive more or
less she slices the dark army guy who's
closest to her and what looks like the
Achilles tendon gets his gun and kills
everybody in the room that's not on her
team in just a few seconds is it the
most believable scenario I've ever seen
probably not Dom could have done this
though she's a trained FBI agent she was
laying on the ground for what ten
minutes at least with time to plan out
what she was gonna do and regardless it
was awesome to watch Dom has been stuck
under the thumb of the dark army for
this entire season and it's been painful
to watch and this felt really good to
see her be able to fight back and it's a
bit sad when she asked to send Darlene
away I don't think she's gonna die so it
doesn't feel like it's all that worrying
that this is last time they're gonna see
each other but I mean it's completely
necessary
because when we go back over and we
catch up with Elliot we see that he can
barely function after him talking with
mr. robot he breaks down he says he
can't do it he doesn't think he can go
through with it and I think this is what
you would expect from a person who's in
the position who's done the things I
mean you would actually expect for him
to be passed out and capacitated
somewhere but I mean as far as where
we're at it would be a little bit odd if
he was able to just throw this hack
together and move on without a breakdown
so it ends on a sour note and I think
that Dom wins the day it's a little bit
sad to see Janice go because I've
enjoyed her particular brand of villainy
but it was also a pretty satisfying and
she got to showcase what we liked about
her and she got to get killed
in a way that is certainly memorable so
yeah we have Elliot he's stuck he's got
mr. robot there and we have to imagine
Darlene's on her way she knows we're all
safe is she knows what they have to do
even if she didn't expect Elliot was
there I would imagine that she would go
there to try to do her part
I imagine the next episode is gonna open
with them getting back together and
we'll see the Alderson siblings activate
once again I mean we're at episode 8
we're approaching the finish line and
we're gonna have to make some movement
on this dais group meeting that we've
been anticipating for several episodes
at this point Christmas can't last
forever like I said I think this was a
tough episode to put together how do you
follow up episode 7 it was so emotional
I think it's that it's job it would be
hard to dislike this episode in that
light and I think there is stuff to
think about with the key and the
original dream and how that played out
but I think right now there are
different things on the table that
Elliot's gonna be facing and I can't
wait to see how it all plays out so let
me know what you think in the comments
how does this change your ideas about
the monster and the key and the dream
what do you think about the Queens
Museum didn't he really go inside there
is that a real thing do you think that
was the last time that DOM and Darlene
will be together or are they gonna see
each other again
and how happy were you when mr. robot
made his return please like this video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already thanks
for watching we'll talk to you soon